SHIGERU MIYAGAWA: MIT
recently did a study
of future of MIT education.
And right at the top,
what we have to do
is to teach teamwork
and leadership
above technical skills.
And the neat thing
about getting students
to work with visual
materials, is
that because there's so much
information, that you've
got to work in teams.
Just having one
perspective is interesting,
but having two perspectives
is really interesting.
And having multiple perspectives
on the same material
is just extraordinary,
and people debate.
This is something else, the
idea of critical thinking.
You really debate based
on whatever evidence
you can find in the image,
and historical and cultural
knowledge that you gain from
your readings and the video.
And so the idea of teamwork
really comes into play.
And you can see people
playing leadership roles.
And people sort of switch
leaders and leadership
as they go from one
image to the next,
depending on what they feel
comfortable talking about.
Here's some things to keep
in mind about incorporating
visual materials.
The first thing that one should
know, we know this already,
is that young people are
exposed to visual materials
by the ton on a daily basis.
And yet, they are never
taught how to interpret them.
What happens with visual
materials, is that you go in,
you react emotionally,
and then you come out.
Without carefully
analyzing the content.
Unlike written material.
Written material, you have
to go through word by word
and think about what is this?
What does this say?
And so it's critical that we
teach how to read visuals.
That's one point.
The second point is that there's
a ton of visuals out there.
You have to curate them.
You can't just throw students
into this collection of visuals
without some sense of knowing
where those visuals come from.
If you want students
to publish the visuals,
then you have to
think about copyright.
And students should be
taught about copyright.
What things you
can and cannot do.
So these are all
21st century skills
that you can teach
with visual material.